may turn out to be a piece of
campaigning genius but the initial
reaction on social media to Ed
Miliband's tablet of stone featuring at
Labour's election pledges you can read
them there has not been universally
positive it certainly attracted a lot of
attention sir to take a look at some
other responses now to tell you there's
only a tiny fraction of the traffic
about what was quickly called the ed
stone lots of them referring to remember
that one the comedy the thick of it
let's just check out first of all what
George Osborne had to say on the Twitter
you can see there be Chancellor saying
carvings a monument for downing street
garden looks like a Sheffield rally
moment once again ed Miliband's judgment
not rock solid the Guardians Claire
Phipps saying party leaders need an age
whose job it is to say a policy is to
like the thick of it stroke actually
featured on the pic of it stroke too far
even for the thick of it and talking of
the thick of it this one from one of the
writers of that comedy he said that I'd
Miliband fills a policy senator and you
wonder why we stopped doing the thick of
it ouch and there's more to come as well
because take a look at this just give
you a sample of what's being said
they're marked hence a great campaign
pulse by an edge shake and useless
stroke weird image Tory's rattled all we
need now is a gigantic pledged monolith
and where they're so a satirical one
there george eaton as well i'm surprised
CeeCee HQ haven't yet Miliband for
planning to take britain back to the
Stone Age you can see that plenty of
scope there for satire and comedy Hugo
reckon bear they journalists saying yes
I've had heavy night but I have never
woken discover I'd commissioned an
eight-foot gravestone with a list of
platitude on it hashtag Millie stoned
there's even more there but let me show
you another son put something that crops
up very quickly you can see they're a
bit of a rip off their of the original
stone there with F miliband's shopping
list or suppose dropping list on it from
semi-skimmed milk there to check with
Justine if we need llewellyn truly many
boards to come